here we go ladies and gentlemen this is
huge news Alex Berenson he's a
journalist says boom I say again boom
the federal fifth Circuit Court appeals
just said Twitter and other social media
platforms don't have an unlimited right
to discriminate against speech let a
thousand flowers bloom hi and there's an
opinion I hope James O'Keefe is
listening somewhere off the distance and
um gearing up for war
here we go it says the first amendment
protects speech It generally prevents
the government from interfering with
people's speech or forcing them to speak
the platforms argue that because they
are host and transmit speech the First
Amendment also gives them an unqualified
license to invalidate laws that hinder
them from censoring speech they don't
like and they say that license entitles
them to pre-inforcement facial relief
against hb20 we reject the platform's
attempts to extract a free willing
censorship right from the Constitution's
Free Speech guarantee the platforms are
not newspapers their censorship is not
speech they're not entitled to
pre-inforcement facial relief is it
fascial is it facial and hb20 is
constitutional because it neither
compels nor obstructs the platform's own
speech in any way The District Court
aired in concluding otherwise and abused
its discretion by issuing a preliminary
injunction the preliminary injunction is
vacated and this case is remanded for
further proceedings consistent with its
opinion
the floodgates have been opened not to
mention not to mention we've seen uh
numerous reports now that the federal
government has been colluding with big
Tech to censor so particularly when it
came to fauci Luke you mentioned this
they went after a fouchy parody account
they were like can we get this one taken
down it's not one of our something like
that the government went after Alex
Berenson the White House I believe it
was the White House contacted Twitter
and said why haven't you banned him yet
yes correct so now he won that case he
won it well he didn't win the case he
got he got uh settlement settlement and
he got the disclosure he got the uh what
do they call it when they could you can
find all of that Discovery you got
Discovery and that's where they found
this communication and uh now he's won
another major victory here so uh this is
fantastic he told me just the beginning
he's going to continue okay I'm glad to
see it yeah um maybe maybe we need a
concerted effort maybe we need to figure
out how we can um I mean anybody who's
been impacted by this needs to file suit
I think we've got a class action already
there are a bunch of Physicians doing
class action against Facebook oh that's
and and that one's really important
especially yeah because they ruined
people's career they really destroyed
people why because fear the public
health authorities in this country
decided they needed to use fear to
follow a zero covet policy and they
believed their Chinese Associates and
professional colleagues that the
lockdown was the only way to do that
that was the first time with this
country of West had ever thought about
locking that it was the Chinese
Communist Party policy I will I will say
this uh as well right now with this
statement here from Alex Berenson uh I
am going to have our lawyers sitting
ready and waiting in case they stand for
tonight uh or or otherwise I mean it is
it is absolutely insane that these
companies think they are immune and and
I've argued this a million times now
that we know there's been direct
collusion I'd be willing to I'd be
willing to bet we can find the same
collusion between Google and the
government that we found between Twitter
and the government and Facebook Mark
Zuckerberg's admission you think
YouTube's cleaning this one I doubt it
absolutely why are they focused on
certainly so you so YouTube can back off
and let conversations in the public
sphere happen
or they can face Discovery and be
included in this wave which will
ultimately create a Cascade of negative
impacts on their platform mainline
Medical Doctors were censored their
voice was taken away from the commons
because they dared to show data and
science that didn't go along with the
narrative and paradigms they wanted
people to go along so seeing this news
it emboldens me it shows me you know
what take me down censor me because we
could fight this in a court of law and I
will if anything happens to me from now
on let's go I now have a little
relationship with you with YouTube and
they've very kindly reinstate it so you
can get reinstated not just yourself but
there's other doctors the AI that's the
problem and they need to adjust that
yeah it's not it's not just that it's
not just that there's other doctors we
can't even mention their names here that
you interviewed that aren't that don't
have a relationship that haven't gotten
their Channel back so so it's not just
this is the issue with rulings like this
what will happen is I assure you that
when this when this he posted this four
hours ago I'm willing to bet that a
legal team game that's working with
YouTube or whatever immediately said we
need to have a meeting right now and I
would imagine part of their advice to
YouTube was
if you do cross that line you could so
I'll we'll put in simple math terms
if you think someone's saying a bad
thing on your platform will cause you
let's say one degree of damage
so you make a move against that to
rectify that one degree of damage you
could then be on the hook for 10 times
as much damage if you censor someone
because you don't like what they've said
and they sue you it may it might open
the floodgates to eliminate all of your
protections so you need to pull back
this is what often happens they'll say
don't fight this battle because it'll
make things worse an example is when it
was what was it Mississippi had that the
abortion law was that Mississippi and
then that so this group was like we're
gonna Sue to stop this and then the
Supreme Court basically wipes out Roe v
Wade this is one of the big issues with
getting involved in legal battle you can
make it worse for yourself when you lose
or you can strategically Retreat and
pull back this makes me think that
Twitter apparently corporations think
they have free speech a corporation an
entity an invisible entity thinks it has
free speech on the U.S Constitution
maybe it does technically but Mega Corps
are different beasts and social media is
like the phone company it's not it
doesn't
choosing who to shut down is not a form
of free speech if you come maybe if you
come into my house and you're saying
something I don't want you to say I
control the land I can I have my free
speech overrides yours I guess that's
the way it works legally but for a
corporation no I think Time's A Change
company I'll tell you I'll tell you what
if YouTube says if if the rules were
this if you violate our policies we will
remove you from the partner program I
would say fair enough yeah it it is
there's I don't believe there's an
obligation for YouTube to sell on my
behalf advertising but to restrict
people's access to your content like we
we've been dealing this with now for the
past couple weeks probably because more
than two months of the election our
thumbnails don't load when we launch the
live stream for this show right now that
you're watching many of you might notice
on the home page of YouTube even if you
do see it it's a gray block and then Ian
will be like Tim the thumbnail sign up
and I'm like and I have to go in and
everybody every night and and and the
issue is we can see that that has a
direct impact on viewers because people
scrolling their homepage won't see the
thumbnail and they just won't out of
sight out of mind we also several times
in this show got a weird YouTube error
when we talked about certain things that
literally happens
so you know look they play these dirty
games they've been playing them with us
for a while now and
it is it is insane to me that YouTube is
basically supposed to be like a common
carrier it's supposed to be like a phone
company it's supposed to be a platform
but it said they act like a newspaper
they have editorial rules they say
here's our editorial rules you have to
abide by sometimes they don't even tell
you the rules there was an instance
where there was a guy we call Voldemort
if you said his name they would delete
your video outright even though it was
never posted in their rules that was the
case right well I I've gone back several
times and asked what the rules are they
won't tell you right yeah they have some
rules listed I know uh one guy I'm not
gonna say his name because I don't want
to come I don't want them coming after
his new show but with no strikes no rule
breaks they deleted his entire channel
300 and something thousand subscribers
you know they did tell us that they were
having sort of they were under sort of a
multinational attack right now with a
lot of misinformation which kind of
interesting to me that somebody's trying
to already stir things up as the
election goes in and to some extent I I
kind of you know I want them not to be
allowing stuff that's designed to harm
us right but they have found that
certain topics are in but just really
quick I think there's no rules because
they want you to be paranoid they want
you to censor yourself they want you to
be scared to even dare mission
accomplish something that that could go
against the the grain or the
establishment and I think it's about the
same yeah 2098 I could lose my license
I'm scared [ __ ] and it's and and let it
out Drew it's a lot more Sinister than
than just like hey let's let's try to
you know keep the rules here because you
look at what the what Facebook was doing
with the FBI Facebook was was colluding
with them giving them information spying
on people getting people's private
messages but they also did that with
covet there's Facebook emails showing
how Zuckerberg was offering Dr fauci
data on users to help the lockdown
policies to help people make sure that
they weren't going outside of their
homes Facebook was volunteering that
information so though the way that they
work together the way that they collude
is far more interconnected than we even
know about I think if we're going to
avoid a Civil War uh it's by giving
people control their social media
networks and their monitors their money
I know they're trying to turn ethereum
into the new Global Currency right now
it's really ethereum that's what it's
pretty much they're like oh they just
took they took ethereum off of proof of
work meaning the miners that were making
it it's no longer that now it's proof of
stake as of like two days ago so whoever
has the ethereum is going to control the
ethereum network basically they created
Fiat they just created another digital
Fiat and it looks like they're going to
try and make that the Global Currency
ethereum and make who's there ethereum
uh who is doing it probably the American
government the world economic Forum the
Chinese government
you know those are probably the three
biggest movers on the planet many other
corporations you're familiar with the
great reasons I see a book right there
about it yeah
you'll be happy what you will own
nothing and you will yeah I'm sorry
that's the quote but it's actually you
will own nothing you will have no
privacy and you will be happy yeah the
actual quote was from a tweet it the
year is was it twenty Thirty Thirty
twenty Thirty I own nothing I have no
privacy and I've never been happier it
was an article in a policy paper that
they were pushing for their vision of
what's going to be happening in the
future which goes along the same
principles of the UN 2030 Vision I just
want I want to point out too that um to
a certain degree owning less stuff will
actually make you happy they say that
when you own stuff your stuff owns you
but this what we're getting from their
vision of it is not exactly what is
meant by owning nothing owning nothing
is like having your necessities and then
foregoing the ridiculous quest for
material Goods like luxuries but their
vision is more like you're going to eat
a bag of crickets and live in a pie I
think they want to strip property right
it's away from people and that's like
the basis of this country basically
that's and that's the basis of Communism
and that you won't be able to escape and
you won't be able to have a car and you
won't be able to transport anymore it's
the worst thing you know like back in
the day if like things got bad you could
be like well I guess I'll go Exile
myself and live in the woods or whatever
or just go off somewhere else there's
nowhere to go anymore they track you
everywhere it's by Design well I don't
know if it's everywhere but that's what
they okay you guys are totally
depressing me yeah I'm stressed about
this because I feel like we're about to
evolve from the liberal economic order
which we've had since 1946 where it's
american-led rules-based economy
military bases to a New World Order
which is like this new Global
technocratic governance where they're
trying to spy on people and make sure
they're not stepping out of line because
they don't want people to go crazy they
don't want people to blow things up they
don't want Hitler to come again I get it
I get the the purpose may be seem like
benevolent but stripping people of their
property rights isn't going to go well
in the United States
um and we need to work together with you
Klaus and you know that uh to make a
better world I I think decentral
property ownership is key man thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there